howard stern howard stern the shock jock
par excellence
really a pioneer in the field of shock
jockery
variously obscene
profane
pro-free speech that's what he is he's
anti-censorship
until
until he and his friends
became the dominant ruling class the
establishment at which point they
defended censorship specifically in the
case
of
neil young trying to get joe rogan
censored from spotify here is
howard stern twisting himself into
logical pretzels to try to defend neil
young without explicitly defending
censorship
i don't think he's for censorship i
don't think
neil young is for censorship i just
think he's saying look i don't want to
be part of this organization
because my music is helping people bring
people to the table and then they're
spreading something as lethal as don't
take the vaccine do this hmm
that makes you know
yeah i you know i'm against any kind of
censorship really you know i really am i
don't like censorship but when you're
talking about life and death like poor
meatloaf got sucked into some weird
cult
i'm against all forms of censorship
really i'm against all forms of
censorship
but
you hear that butt
that butt is doing a lot of work there
mr stern
neil young he's not for censorship
neil young just explicitly called to
censor joe rogan on spotify
neil young just said if you don't take
joe rogan off spotify then you don't get
neil young i want all my songs gone and
then then spotify said okay they're gone
i said what i said yeah they're gone
no no guys i'm serious i'm going to take
all my songs off yeah i know i know we
heard you neil they're gone bye
don't don't let the door hit you guys
come on don't i'm serious yeah okay
right because they weren't going to
stand for that good for spotify
and now howard stern is defending neil
young and but try but he he's positioned
himself as the anti-censorship guy and
yet now he is overtly
defending censorship
a lot of conservatives are wondering
what happened to these guys
what happened
howard stern was
neil young
and and crosby stills and nash they had
the free speech tour
in 2006 what happened
uc berkeley all those hippies they had
the free speech movement in the 1960s
what happened
they were all against censorship now
there are the censors
they were never against censorship
they were only against your censorship
they were never against censorship
they just wanted
to stop your censorship of their stupid
ideas and their perversions
the minute that they
broke the conservative censorship of
their terrible ideas and their
perversions
they reinstituted censorship but it was
a censorship of your good ideas and your
normal flourishing way of behavior that
that's what they did
as i wrote in a a particular book called
speechless controlling words controlling
minds uh where's the bell it's gone okay
that's fine
the the battle that we're talking about
here
is not a battle between free speech on
the one hand
and censorship on the other
it's a battle between two competing sets
of standards
it's a every society is going to have
taboos every society is going to have
limits
the genius of the free speech movements
in the anti-censorship movements
was that they convinced a society
that we could have absolutely unfettered
license and that would be totally you
could just say whatever that's obviously
not true that's never been true in any
society ever at least of all in america
there were always going to be limits
ask howard stern if he supports teaching
the bible in schools you're against
censorship of all sorts right howard
okay so certainly we shouldn't censor
the bible bible from schools
one it's the most important book ever
written from which all of western
civilization springs so
surely you said oh you don't oh that's
so weird i thought you were against
censorship
oh right you won't even support joe
rogan bringing on well-respected medical
experts to discuss
the the major medical public health
questions of our day of course they
support censorship i'm so glad you found
this video because i have been told by a
number of you out there that even though
you have rung the bell and subscribed to
this channel you're not getting
notifications when the new videos come
out isn't that's kind of strange i don't
i wonder why
why that might be youtube so if you want
to get
notifications and the full uncensored
show for free head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher google play
wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe leave a five star review to
the michael knowles show we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you